[Música]
es un placer estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
aumenta la tensión entre China y Estados
Unidos el fortalecimiento de Los lazos
militares de este último país con Taiwán
las acusaciones de Washington contra
Beijing sobre el origen del Coby 19 y
sus advertencias de no suministrar armas
a Rusia para su guerra en Ucrania y
otros aspectos han intensificado los
choques Alejandro cada vez más la
posibilidad de normalizar su relaciones
en Afganistán reabrieron las
universidades pero sí la presencia de
las mujeres tras el veto establecido por
los talibanes solo los hombres tienen
permitido recibir educación
uno de los iconos de Australia está en
peligro de extinción hablamos de los
koalas cuya población se está viendo
disminuida desde hace varios años debido
a los incendios forestales y la
deforestación echaremos un vistazo A
cómo se intentan preservar las pocas
decenas de miles de ejemplares que aún
quedan en el país
iniciamos este recorrido por el
continente asiático con la interminable
atención entre dos potencias mundiales
les hablo de China y Estados Unidos El
acercamiento de Taiwán con Washington
Los lazos que fortalece Beijing con
Rusia en el marco de la guerra en
Ucrania el posible origen del Coby 19
por una fuga en un laboratorio chino y
la prohibición de la app china tiktok en
agencias federales de Estados Unidos son
solo algunos de los recientes capítulos
de choques e intercambio de acusaciones
entre ambas partes temas en los cuales
ahondaremos en esta edición por ello me
acompaña aribel Contreras coordinadora
de la licenciatura de negocios globales
de la universidad iberoamericana aribel
Gracias por aceptar esta invitación
china anunció Un aumento de su
presupuesto militar en más de un 7% este
año argumentando amenazas externas y
señaló específicamente a Estados Unidos
país que ha venido reforzando lazos
militares con Taiwán que a su vez ha
visto como Beijing ha incrementado las
exhibiciones militares en sus
alrededores De qué manera esa creciente
atención Washington podría afectar o
tocar a Taiwán
Muchas gracias por la gentil la
invitación Paula y sin duda estás
tocando justamente
esta llaga en esta situación ante la
coyuntura que estamos viviendo Taiwán se
ha convertido en el enclave en la
confrontación actual entre China y
Estados Unidos a la luz de los intereses
geopolíticos y económicos que esta Isla
representa no solamente por la
producción de los chips semiconductores
sino porque justo apunta a China a los
lazos históricos pero también estamos
viendo que Washington a lo largo de las
últimas décadas Aunque oficialmente no
lo reconoce como un país nación si da
proveeduría en cuestión militar Así que
china está trazando de manera muy clara
y puntual sus líneas rojas de que Taiwán
es parte de territorio de de lo que es
China y y estamos viendo que ante esta
escalada y esta atención tal vez en un
mediano largo plazo pudiera convertirse
en un espejo de lo que estamos viviendo
y viendo hoy a la luz de este conflicto
entre Ucrania y Rusia Así que es algo
que no debemos de dejar de perder de
vista Paula
precisamente ya que toca el tema de la
invasión rusa a Ucrania china presentó
recientemente un plan de paz para
desescalar el conflicto es viable que
sea aceptado y tomado en cuenta
fíjate Paula que son doce puntos de
manera muy clara donde lo primero que
china pone sobre la mesa es que se
retiren las sanciones hacia Rusia que
haya un alejamiento ya de cualquier tipo
de tropas presentes en territorio
ucraniano sin embargo ha sido muy mal
recibido por parte de occidente se
considera una propuesta escéptica porque
creen que en realidad es un plan que
favorece a Rusia sin embargo yo no estoy
en total de acuerdo con esta
puntualización mediática que ha generado
Porque al menos yo digo pues al menos
china ha puesto algo en qué momento
Estados Unidos que esté proponiendo algo
finalmente
esta situación Me parece que más allá de
si uno está a favor de Ucrania o de
Rusia la puesta de china en esta
política
semi neutral que ha mostrado frente al
mundo desde este conflicto es que al
menos le está apostando a la paz algo
están careciendo occidente donde más
allá de Turquía o el intento fallido de
las Naciones Unidas de mediar vemos Que
occidente Únicamente se está enfocando a
contener abonar para que Ucrania de
batalla pero no hay otra propuesta de
paz Me parece que eso Es verdaderamente
preocupante otro capítulo de La
incesante atención es el posible origen
del covid 19 y la prohibición de la
aplicación china tiktok en teléfonos de
funcionarios gubernamentales de Estados
Unidos alegando un riesgo a la seguridad
nacional Beijing niega estas acusaciones
es decir todo esto es una suma de crisis
Así es Paula y me parece que lo has
dicho muy pertinente estamos viendo que
esta confrontación ya crece en un
espiral donde por un lado es una
confrontación de narrativas a la luz
desde la era Trump con respecto al
origen del virus que la Organización
Mundial de la Salud nos debe la
humanidad explicaciones pero donde china
niega que el origen sea en el
laboratorio de wuhan Mientras que el FBI
la DEA y otras instancias al interior de
Estados Unidos argumentan que sí fue el
origen del laboratorio y no del mercado
de guja otra confrontación sin duda es
la parte tecnológica donde por un lado
Estados Unidos está prohibiendo
exportaciones de chips semiconductores y
algunos componentes tecnológicos que
abonan a la industria China y en el
camino se llevan entre las patas a la
empresa
que pertenece tiktok tiktok es una
aplicación que agrupa más de mil
millones de habitantes y que desde
occidente se ha construido una de que
toda esta información cuando uno se da
de alta pues constituye una amenaza
nacional para los países cuyos usuarios
la descargan Y por supuesto tu pregunta
de A dónde apostarle apostarle a que
esto crecerá estaremos viendo nuevas
confrontaciones continuarán la
ciberguerras continuarán estos este
choque de no solo de narrativas sino
esta confrontación geopolítica
geoeconómica pero también tecnológica
entre China y Estados Unidos y eso no
son muy buenas noticias me parece que es
alarmante preocupante porque esto no
abona y sin duda esto lo que alimenta es
hablar hoy de una segunda guerra fría
Dos punto cero Paula
agradecemos a nivel Contreras por su
análisis nos vamos a Afganistán allí
reabrieron las universidades pero no
para las mujeres recordemos que el
régimen talibal les prohibió asistir y
recibir educación un hecho que marca la
represión de la que son víctimas en este
mes de marzo en el que se conmemora la
reivindicación de los derechos de las
mujeres nos preguntamos hasta cuándo
este tipo de vetos seguirán presentes el
informe es de Samuel Salgado
los hombres regresan a la universidad en
Afganistán luego de la pausa invernal
mujeres fuera de las aulas en las calles
enviando las restricciones de los
talibanes que regresaron al poder en
agosto de 2021 desde entonces los
derechos de las mujeres han sido
cercenados según la ONU right a pesar de
la promesa inicial de moderación los
talibanes están replicando las políticas
misóginas que ejercieron durante el
primer periodo hace más de 20 años
las mujeres no pueden ir a la
universidad
aporta cerrada farija se reúne con otras
manifestantes
todas estamos reunidas aquí para exigir
una misma demanda las puertas de las
universidades y escuelas deben reabrirse
y debemos usar nuestro derecho
inalienable a tener un país
autosuficiente y bueno
sin educación no hay desarrollo
económico dos años antes de la retoma
del poder talibán las mujeres
representaban el 21% del mercado laboral
y en las grandes ciudades como kabul y
gerat las aulas estaban compuestas en
partes casi iguales por afganas y
afganos un panorama completamente
distinto al actual
mi hermana intenta estudiar en casa me
ha pedido que le enseñe lo que yo
aprendo de inglés aquí así como
informática pero no es suficiente
la comunidad internacional no reconocerá
el régimen talibán hasta que este
respete los derechos humanos y de las
mujeres la falta de mujeres educadas y
de reconocimiento internacional ahonda
la crisis humanitaria que vive
Afganistán
en muchas ocasiones cuando se habla de
Australia inmediatamente se viene a la
mente los koalas Pero esto podría
cambiar su población ha estado en
declive durante varios años y desde que
los recientes incendios forestales
devastaron los bosques el animal fue
incluido en la lista de especies en
peligro de extinción del país en 2022
los koalas el querido icono australiano
están amenazados en los últimos años los
incendios forestales australianos han
devastado las ya mermadas poblaciones de
koalas en 2022 el animal fue incluido
oficialmente en la lista de animales en
peligro de extinción en queensland Nueva
gales del sur y la región de campera
devorata Bart es un activista koala
también es conocida como la mujer koala
la fundación de koala Australia no
estimado un descenso del 30% de la
especie desde 2018 hemos destruido cerca
del 80% de su hábitat y el 20% restante
está bajo una gran presión debido a la
agricultura las minas de Carbón la
construcción de carreteras entre otros
factores
los incendios forestales de 2019 y 2020
quemaron 12,6 millones de hectáreas de
terreno
más de 61,000 koalas quedaron en medio
de las llamas la fundación Calcula que
hoy quedan unas pocas decenas de miles y
sólo queda el 20% de los hábitats
natural del koala
[Música]
el factor más importante para mantener
la población de koalas con buena salud
es que ellos se puedan mover y que no
estén en ambientes sobrepoblados sino se
estresarán y desarrollarán enfermedades
renales leucemia o clamidia
la media la planilla una enfermedad de
transmisión sexual se está extendiendo
rápidamente entre los animales en 2008
alrededor del 10% de la población estaba
infectada hoy 8 décadas están expuestos
la clamidia es una infección
bacteriológica que puede desencadenar
conjuntivitis y afectar también el
sistema reproductor de las hembras y
puede generar infertilidad
esta hembra está siendo examinada
se le presta toda la atención ya que
todavía es capaz de reproducirse
este animal lo catalogamos de alto nivel
de conservación es joven No tiene
enfermedades se puede reproducir y esto
aumenta la posibilidad de aumentar la
población de koalas
que han sido tratados en este hospital
55 han regresado a la naturaleza
y para el cierre les dejo este dato
recientemente Japón descubrió que cuenta
con 7000 Islas que no sabía que tenía
según un mapeo digital de la autoridad
de información geoespacial de Japón
actualmente hay 14.125 islas en
territorio japonés más del doble de la
cifra de 6.852 que se manejaba
oficialmente desde un informe de 1987 de
la guardia costera sin duda son nuevas
alternativas para ir de vacaciones
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarlos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios a
la cuenta de Twitter que aparece en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web France 24.com Y no
olvides nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]